welcome back to las vegas now in today's
legal minute we're learning about pool
safety laws eric palacios from eric
palacios and associates the sponsors of
this segment tells us more
i'm eric palacios welcome to the legal
minute this week's question is what are
pool safety laws in nevada number one
you must have a self-closing gate and
this must operate properly
it's a good recommendation to also have
a separate enclosure if you have small
children
it's always important to have an adult
supervising small children
and finally be very careful with doggy
doors crawling children can easily go
out of doggy doors and drown if you have
guests with small children you're always
responsible for their safety
we hope everyone has a safe summer we'll
see you next week here on the legal
minute
and you can always get more information
by giving eric palacios and associates a
call that phone number 444-7777
you can also visit their website at
ericpalacioslaw.com
las vegas now we'll be right back